president biden has decided he's going
to go after republican governors
accusing them of trying to undermine his
vaccine mandate which will entail force
businesses with more than 100 employees
to require their own short staffed
people
to get the shot or undergo weekly
coveted testing but also keep an eye at
the door to make sure everybody coming
through has a vax car that's how it's
rolling out in new york we'll see if it
spreads from here the president claims
republicans are the issue but a
quinnipiac poll finds 51 percent of
americans disapprove of his mandate some
in the mainstream media are reporting
and following president biden's lead
with this us versus them approach take a
look
i think we have to stop coddling people
when it comes to this and the vaccine
saying oh you can't shame them you can't
call them stupid you can't call them
silly again yes they are the people who
ate and embedded trump are stupid
because they believed his big lie
the people who are not getting vaccines
who are believing the lies on the
internet instead of science it's time to
start shaming them what else or leave
them behind
because they are keeping the majority of
americans behind you want to leave black
and brown people behind too there don
lemon because they also make up a
healthy percentage of those people who
have decided that right now they're
going to remain unvaccinated the
hypocrisy here my other favorite word
starts with h2
anyway
i'm not going to say that
morgan
well uh
so much to unpack here my mind
immediately went to and i know you
talked about it yesterday about nicki
minaj and her tweets and what was
interesting is like clearly the tweets
about the vaccine that she did were a
little ridiculous but what was more
telling was the reaction and
the instinct from certain people on the
left to shame no matter what right
instead of trying to educate but as you
just said harris it is all about
hypocrisy where is the president when
he's criticizing republican governors
why didn't the president criticize
obama's masculist birthday party or the
met gala where the elite were able to be
unmasked but not the staff right or the
president's july 4th um party uh picnic
that he had at the white house that i
believe the washington post reported had
at least several hundred people in
attendance so it's just another example
of rules for thee uh but not for me and
clearly the president decided that this
is a political fight that he wants to
have he wants to go after republican
governors especially those who may want
to challenge him in 2024. you know ben
this is such low-hanging fruit because
if you make it all about politics and
you go after trump's supporters you
don't have to then
talk about those people who look like
don lemon joy reid and myself and look i
don't want to oversell it it is what it
is we paid the highest price 57 at one
point of of the hospitalizations and
deaths people of color and so we know
that we are vulnerable to this disease
and rather than reach out and try and
help it's a further division in this
country and you don't have to know how
anybody votes to know that they have
their own separate ideas about being
vaccinated or not you can reach them on
an ideal basis they're intelligent well
look this is this is one of the biggest
and i think one of the sickest political
moves that i have seen in my lifetime
the democratic party and the white house
understand they need a wedge issue right
now to divide the country on purpose and
and let me remind don lemon we're not
anti-vaxx conservatives we're the ones
that came up with the damn vaccine we're
the ones that did operation warp speed
donald trump is the one that moved this
forward and you guys were on tv going
i'm not taking a trump vaccine so i'm
sorry i don't buy it there but but let's
go back to this white house decision
they decided we have a disaster a
dumpster fire in afghanistan with 10
percent of americans left behind we have
a dumpster fire with the economy right
now how do we galvanize our base and
make sure that our poll numbers stop
falling and they said you know what
here's what we're going to do we're
going to go out into america and we're
going to divide based on politics on
covid 19 vaccine and i tell people this
do not take their bait remember the
americans in afghanistan remember what
they're doing to our economy i truly
believe the constitution is going to
save us on this one i believe states are
going to win on this one and this is a
sick political move solely to sure up
his base to say hate the republicans
they're why you're dying and that is not
the facts here so i am going to go there
because you use the h word i was talking
about and and i don't like to put terms
like this there so
it's hate yes
this is driven by hate it is hypocrisy
and hate yeah why
yeah it's exactly what ben said i mean
we're having like a symbiotic moment
then because that's exactly what i was
thinking and was planning to say he's
right they are using hate they are using
division to distract from all of the
multiple crises in this country
so
so how how can you legitimately say that
you are the president of the total
united states when 75 million people
didn't vote for you and now you want to
leverage some hate toward them and
they're not i mean many of them are
vaccinated yeah i mean
where is this coming from this is our
great uniter in chief he used the word
unity more than a dozen times on
inauguration day and instead he's the
divider in chief and don lemon boy he's
probably auditioning to be a
speechwriter for this administration
with that kind of mafia-like language
which is underscored by biden saying the
vaccinated have a right to be angry
cedric richmond i will run over those
governors he wants a fight with
governors as he vacations by the way
he's on a plane now to go on a beachside
vacation he wants to fight with
governors to distract from everything
going on that's it emily i just find it
appalling that our commander-in-chief
has his anger reserved for americans
remember he called the taliban merely
challenging but he said that we should
condemn the unvaccinated we have here
don lemon calling unvaccinated stupid
those are fellow americans with
legitimate questions as we talked about
yesterday he said oh i thought you were
smarter than we thought no one's trying
to reach these people and they're not we
don't know how all of them vote right
what i was going to say was that it
flows from the top so for example the
fact that the commander-in-chief invited
a celebrity who had questions about the
vaccine to come to the white house to
engage with her to share information
with her absolutely that's how that
should happen but instead the rest of
our